this will not be a normal one Nova
productions video that's because I'm
getting a patreon but first I need to
show you why so at 5 a.m. on a recent
Saturday morning I woke up left my
apartment walked downtown took a bus
took a plane took a bus took a train
then arrived here an open field it may
seem strange I traveled over 200 miles
to an open field but this was no
ordinary open field this was Argyll ttan
a place that was once a story in every
major newspaper worldwide now this place
may sound familiar to you I talked about
it in twl episode 3 Argyll t'nuk cysts
but only according to some maps it's a
paper town back in the old days mapping
companies devoted an enormous amount of
resources to just figuring out what
existed where they had to survey every
physical place map every Road plot every
mountain just so they knew what to put
on maps some figured out though that
they didn't have to go out and survey
places they could just copy the
information from other maps they were
after all mapping the exact same world
so in theory there would be no way to
tell if they were plagiarizing that's
why Paper Towns were created these towns
never existed in real life they were
just randomly and arbitrarily placed if
competing maps suddenly started listing
paper towns such as Argyll ttan their
source would know and could prove that
they were plagiarizing since there's
certainly no way that they would get the
false information from surveying modern
maps are constantly updated and adjusted
using new technologies like satellite
and GPS but a good amount of information
on our 21st century maps comes from
centuries old maps modern day companies
such as TomTom Intelli Atlas acquired
much of their information from slightly
older companies who acquired their
information from even older companies
and so on and so forth so remnants of
those 19th and 20th century maps
sometimes will show up today
Argyll ttan is one of those remnants
sometime down the line some company
place Argyll tanaan the map as a
copyright trap and decade after decade
nobody noticed even when it got onto
digital maps nobody's actually sure when
it got there
tella Atlas who sourced mapping
information for Google in the region
tried to figure out where Argyll
Tunisian ate it from but came out
inconclusive after it was pointed out
that in truth our goal today is just
this field Google
the town from its listings in the area
there's no trace of the paper town that
once received worldwide media attention
there are no signs no souvenirs nothing
even for perhaps the most famous fake
town ever so now is when I talk about
money if there's no way I'll ever
convince you to contribute to my patreon
you can go but I do encourage you to
hear me out I was able to do such a
ridiculous thing as traveling 200 miles
to an empty field because of your guys's
support of the channel I think this
video is much better than the original
video I made about our Kelton partially
because I was able to go to argl Tintin
and I want to do things like that more
I've grown enormously and through
adsense licensing and freelance this
channel is now basically my job I make
enough through these sources to support
myself but I want this channel to
improve that's why I've started this
patreon every dollar you give to my
patreon will be spent directly on the
channel I'm serious about that I will
not take a dime of what you contribute
I'm even going to release a monthly
report showing you where your money went
the cool thing about this arrangement is
that the two or five or ten dollars you
contribute will come right back to you
in the form of a better video you will
be directly affecting the quality and
quantity of when over-production videos
there are a couple of things I want to
spend this money on as with this argyll
Tunisia I think there's value in getting
real footage of real places along with
doing research and interviews on
location some of the money will likely
go to travel expenses to get to these
places additionally I'd love to hire
animators and sound designers and others
to improve the quality and quantity of
my videos I'm not going to change format
I promise you I will always have the
same simple clear animations in my
videos
they'll just be cleaner and smoother so
a big part of the money will go to this
mad push for better production quality
I've tried to create some really
rewarding rewards and only $2.00 per
video you'll have early access to my
videos access to the behind the scenes
patreon feed and you can wipe your
conscience clean for using adblock at $5
you'll get a handwritten letter and
stickers sent to wherever you live
fifteen dollars gets you into a super
secret group chat with me and other
high-level supporters and your name will
be eternal eyes in the description of
all videos you support twenty dollars
per video will get you an
awesome-looking win over productions
t-shirt if there are some higher tiers
to
I won't go over them here because I know
many people will actually use them also
just to be clear at whatever tier you
support you'll also get the rewards of
the lower levels so if you have the
means to I would love your support on
patreon I don't need this money to keep
doing the channel I only want it to
improve the channel so thank you and
good night